I fell hopelessly in love 15 years ago I
was only 16 years old a junior in high
school but Stacey Carson was a mature
sophisticated 18 year old and as far as
I could tell she was absolutely perfect
drop dead gorgeous incredibly kind a ton
of fun to hang out with and she had a
way of making everyone she talked to
feel as though they were the most
special person in the world she had my
heart when the opportunity came to ask
her out I seize the moment a friend
called one night to tell me that she had
just split with her boyfriend so I put
on my oversized green suit and tie and I
sprayed on way too much cologne I
grabbed a rose for my mom's flower vase
and I jumped into my brother's red 1987
chevrolet camaro and i sped down to the
high school two blocks away arriving
just in time to see Stacey exiting the
school after finishing her after school
dance rehearsals I put my gasps my foot
to the gas and I sped across the parking
lot I can do a screeching halt in front
of Stacey no doubt she was terrified and
I swung open that big heavy door and
jumped and slid across the hood not
extended the rose
and then without even thinking the words
that came out of my mouth where will you
marry me I was shocked because this is
not what I wanted to say I was even more
surprised when she actually said yes
because that's who she was and then she
laughed and I laughed we laughed
together for a while and then I asked
her to attend the winter ball with me to
which he obliged I spent the next two
weeks doing everything I could to make
sure I would be the perfect day for her
including taking dance lessons because
she loved dancing and I was terrible at
it but that wasn't going to stop me and
the night of the dance came and it was
magical we danced the night away I was
falling in love five years later I asked
Stacy Carson that same big question this
time on purpose and she said this time
without laughing yes and on August
nineteenth 2006 at 1pm we were married
it was another magical moment we were in
love five years passed approaching our
fifth wedding anniversary and a lot had
changed I was working 80 plus hours per
week for a crazy consulting firm and my
wife was working even harder to take
care of our six month old baby boy Jake
we were both completely exhausted I came
home one night after a regular day in
the office 2 a.m. and i walked in to
find my poor wife sitting on the kitchen
floor with tears streaming down her
mascara stained face she looked at me
and she said why aren't you hear from
you when I need you and then without
even thinking the words that came out of
my mouth were I'm doing the best I can
for this family why aren't you more
appreciative and I went to bed that
night ashamed and asking myself the
question what happened to our hopeless
love is this a sign that it's not meant
to be I found the
these questions in the work of dr.
Jennifer finlayson fife a marriage and
family counselor from the University of
Boston from Boston University in her
work she teaches that love those through
three phases phase one love without
knowledge this is the blissfully in love
phase that we all enjoy when our first
falling in love this is the phase when
your partner is always on your mind and
you're willing to do anything for her or
him including taking dance lessons in
this phase your brain is actually
addicted to love your brain enjoys
heightened levels of neurotransmitters
adrenaline dopamine and serotonin all
which formed this crazy cocktail of love
that leaves you feeling joy
vulnerability and complete love so it
seems but this phase will not last
forever because eventually that
heightened level of euphoria goes away
and you enter phase two knowledge
without love this is the might as well
be roommates phase
in this phase reality sets in and you
start to notice the small things and the
big things about your partner that are
failing to meet your expectations and
you stop trying to impress this is the
phase you realize that love is hard this
is where I was on that fateful night at
2am but the beautiful thing is that love
can be better than that and those who
choose to leave that phase will enter
phase 3 knowledge with love in this
phase you still have a full appreciation
for your partner's weaknesses and faults
you still know exactly how your
relationship is failing to meet your
needs lets you choose not to dwell on
them instead you choose to focus on
improving yourself for your partner
because love is worth it and when the
two partners equally commit to working
on self-improvement they can grow in 2
phase 3 and at that point you can really
enjoy the fruits of long lasting love
and companionship Stacy and I have been
married 10 years this August and in a
few days we welcome our third child into
our family I love her and we are not
always in phase 3 but we know how to get
there and we know that it's worth it and
we're both committed to working toward
it every single day so I want to leave
you with a few tips that I've learned
through my 10 years of marriage which
doesn't make me an expert but also not a
novice I like to consider myself an
apprentice of love tip number one learn
how to love dr. Gary Chapman in his new
york times bestselling book the five
love languages teaches us that people
feel loved in different ways your love
language maybe physical touch whereas
yours maybe words of affirmation this
distinction does not matter in phase one
but it does in phase two I know that
stacy is
happy and feeling love when I speak a
specific dialect of physical touch the
daily foot massage I must have been high
on dopamine the day I committed to that
one advice number to learn how to fight
dr. John Gottman is the master at this
in his 30-plus year longitudinal study
he came to to I think relevant
conclusions one greater than sixty
percent of relationship conflict is
unresolvable it's simply a difference of
opinions and number two the marital
masters learn to fight with a smile on
their face I know this is easy to say
and I know it's a lot harder to do trust
me but I also know that it's worth it so
next time you're in a fight don't try to
be right try to understand your
partner's point of view try to argue
with compassion finally advice number
three learn how to forgive unfortunately
I have seen how an unwillingness to
forgive can tear apart families the
longer you're with someone the more
likely it is that feelings will be hurt
that's just the reality of love and if
we let that hurt feelings linger for too
long they will poison your ability to
live everyday expressing those love
languages to live every day arguing with
compassion they'll prevent you from
enjoying the true joys of long laughs
deep lasting relationships that I enjoy
every day with Stacey so that's it no
big secret that's how it works for me so
next time you find yourself in a
long-term relationship and things get
rocky because trust me I promise they
will rather than asking is this meant to
be first try asking what more can I do
and then get to work because it's hard
but I can tell you that it's worth it
thank
you